hi so this episode of ask I am coming to
you from my family vacation we're at the
beach I know I haven't asked of you a
question in a long time kind of forgot
about those so my question to you is
what are you doing in the summer do you
have the beach do you enjoy doing
nothing do you take summer classes
whatever it is you do leave a comment
and maybe even post a video response
with some of those crazy adventures that
you have during the summer but not too
crazy a lot of you guys complain that I
don't answer enough questions or answer
your questions seriously well either way
this is gonna be a rapid-fire ask I did
where I'm gonna answer a bunch of
questions in a short amount of time
ready words for you I don't know what
what are they here kinda music I love
nineties rock I love anything sounds
good I love Kelly Clarkson girl of the
band tool what did you pay for Michael
Jackson song a moment of silence please
thriller
how do you make videos in the Apple
store I use built-in iSight on the IMAX
are you into sports playing volleyball
watching football and hockey go pits and
no I have not read or seen Twilight what
case do I get for my iPhone a white in
case slider they actually don't like
putting a case on my iPhone but he needs
it only website question so you can
leave your questions I just say not calm
if I were to get a dog what kind of job
would I get that kind a King Charles
Spaniels have I ever met hotforwords yes
I met her at YouTube live how do you get
over the fear of people making fun of
you while making videos in public I know
just keep doing it it gets easier will I
order a pizza in English accent hello
yes I'd like to order a pizza please yes
a pizza a pizza a pizza but a pizza that
you feel about cheese and so did my
pepperoni oh you're not open then I
guess
do you have people to help you with your
videos like come up with ideas film and
help you with other stuff
yep I do it all myself editing shooting
producing writing you actually don't
write I just kind of turn like am I to
start talking have a dog will come jog
would I be like I mean yes is it for ask
i J episode number 40
episode number 14 make sure you check
out all of my fun other videos on
youtube.com slash other edges soon I'll
be updating from vacation and all my
mobile photos on Flickr Commons / I just
seen all of the links from the sidebar
and don't forget if you medians or your
questions to leave comments below ask me
questions on my website I just sing calm
ask me questions on Twitter and of
course well oh wait video responses I
always forget that one okay see you guys
next time